it's understandable that people want to
do the kinds of things they want to do
they want their freedom to do that but
there comes a time when you're dealing
with a public health crisis that could
involve you your family and everyone
else that something
supersedes that need to do exactly what
you want to do no dr fauci isn't talking
about obama's big birthday blowout
filled with all the celebs and
dubious dancing techniques that party
was held without masks and inside a tent
was he
melting off about that he's talking
about sturgis an outdoor motorcycle
rally in south dakota
now this i'm having deja vu the same
thing happens last year's event
the one the media also freaked out over
calling it a super spreader well it
turns out those concerns were bogus
out of 460 000 attendees
there was just point one percent
positive coveted cases
well that didn't stop msnbc panic pusher
joy reid
as events like the sturgis motorcycle
rally become a super spreader in the
making with its 700
000 attendees certain to spread covet
all across the country
republicans are still screaming freedom
it's about life and death republicans
know what side to be on and it seems
that they have chosen to be on the side
of death
coming from a party that embraces
abortion on demand joining me now south
dakota governor christie known governor
great to see you haven't seen you in a
while um do you care to weigh in on
being on the side of death this weekend
at sturgis
well you just made an excellent point i
think it's interesting that this side to
this political party the democrats who
embrace
getting abortion on demand are accusing
us of embracing death when we're just
allowing people to make personal choices
and have personal responsibility over
when they want to assemble when they
want to gather and spend time outdoors
enjoying their way of life so we've had
a fantastic event here in south dakota
the rally will end
tomorrow or sunday i guess and they're
having a fantastic time we're glad
everybody made the trip to south dakota
now we checked the new york times
website before we went on air tonight
and i think the seven day average of
covet deaths is about point one
a point one right now in south dakota so
you have among uh the best uh results
now given the fact that you didn't lock
down you didn't do the mass mandates and
it seems like you have an enormous
amount of circulating immunity natural
immunity from prior exposures does that
track with what you're seeing
yes it does we have that going on we
also have over 50 percent of our
population is vaccinated and the folks
that are visiting south dakota you know
we need to remind them that that people
came last year out of 460 000 visitors
we had last year to the rally the
department of health tracked for many
weeks after that and all we were able to
verify was 125 cases from the sturgis
bike rally last year this year we're
taking precautions people can get tested
if they want to we've got medical help
available if people would like it and we
are conducting this in a way that
certainly protects people's freedoms
it's been a great event and what dr
fauci is doing by constantly targeting
the sturgis bike rally by constantly
focusing on south dakota and ignoring
liberals who gather every single day and
their hypocrisy is just wrong i think
it's
it's unfortunate he's building a
distrust into his profession because we
need our public health officials we need
to be able to trust them and he's just
gotten political and picked winners and
losers based on who he likes and who he
doesn't well i don't think he freaked
out about lollapalooza but they had some
vacuums
they had some like vax requirement for
attendees but it was outside and they
they had you know very few uh infections
as well i want to ask you about
something we just mentioned which the
wide administration is clearly floating
to see the reaction a potential federal
move to prevent interstate travel among
those who are not fully vaccinated
thereby isolating
people all over this country now we
don't know if this is a serious
consideration but it's obviously
in the minds of some of these
administration officials given uh what
they're seeing in some parts of the
country
your reaction
well i wouldn't doubt it if they were
considering it because we've already
seen different directives come down from
the federal government to our states
that some governors are just complying
with and many like me are not and when
this federal administration when this
white house when joe biden oversteps his
constitutional authority and takes away
people's rights to make decisions that
they're supposed to make for themselves
we will stand up governors many times
are the last line of defense to help
protect these freedoms that americans
have enjoyed and remember if they come
forward with a directive like that we've
never seen that in this country before
it's unprecedented and it is exactly the
opportunity that we all need to stand up
and remind this federal government of
what their job is what their job isn't
and remember we cannot have leaders
overstep their authority especially in a
time of crisis that's when we break the
country uh sorry governor one more thing
uh the migrants who've come into the
country hundreds and hundreds of
thousands 1.4 million have been quote
encountered whatever that means on the
southern border yeah are you alerted to
uh the the deposit of migrants in your
state when they arrive are you ever told
well
well remember this laura i have my
national guard down there in the
southern border i have close to 50
members down there right but they're
still coming to your state governor
they're still coming now they're not
they're not none of them are coming to
your state
not that i'm aware of because i
communicated with all of those
non-profits in our state that would
accept those types of individuals and i
told them they all need to be licensed
they need to be licensed to be in the
state of south dakota and if they wanted
to continue to be licensed and to do
work in our state which we want them we
welcome them we have great partnerships
that this is something that we'll be
watching and evaluating what they do to
break federal law and to violate the
trust of the state of south dakota so
does that include catholic charities
does that include catholic charities
because they've been funneling migrants
all over the country
well i was down there in the southern
border and that's exactly who was
funneling them all over the country and
our national guard originally was
observing and spotting these individuals
turning them over to border patrol who
then was directed to immediately turn
them over to non-profits who put them on
planes and buses and distributed them so
so what we've done in south dakota i
think is strategic we've got our guys
down there our soldiers are down there
making sure we're stopping the drugs and
the human trafficking that's coming and
getting individuals and but also making
sure we're communicating with those
non-profits
yeah governor and they care so much
about covet but they're just waltzing
right in with covent uh thank you so
much and that's fascinating information
about how you're uh trying to stop the
influx of migrants into your state
governor we hope everyone has a great
time this weekend uh is safe and we'll
check back with you soon thanks so much
great thanks laura hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else